today I'll stick to football mock draft
Wednesday instead of mock draft Monday
and we have a lot of news to talk about
so I love about January every day we sit
down and do this podcast we have news to
talk about connor rogers matt miller a
lot to get to today but first i want to
remind people cuz we're two weeks away
from the Senior Bowl January 20th in
January 22nd will be a draft picks tap
room on Dolphin Street 7:30 until they
kick us out we're going to record our
podcast we're gonna answer your
questions we're gonna hang out so it's
going to be you're gonna walk in we're
gonna record the pod we're gonna head
out koozies we're gonna drink beer we're
gonna answer your draft questions both
on and off air Connor it is going to be
a ridiculously good time it always is
draft picks is one of our favorite
places that we throw you know one of our
tailgates one of our events it's a great
time obviously we're also gonna be there
Super Bowl week not a traffic's we're
gonna be in Miami Florida Super Bowl
week and we have an event on February
1st that Saturday at 1:00 p.m. you know
we'll give you more details on the
location of the venue and how you get
there and all of that but keep in mind
if you're gonna be in the Miami area
during Super Bowl week you better catch
us as well if you can't catch us at
mobile or maybe you just want to keep
hanging out with us for a couple of
weeks straight we're okay with that but
Matt some giant news before we sat down
to the show today and we are very
excited that this dropped we talked
about it a ton on Monday we said listen
if you're the Carolina Panthers and you
like Matt rule you do not let Matt rule
go to jersey you did not let him speak
to the New York Giants and that is
exactly what they did Matt rule is
officially gonna be the head coach of
the Panthers here Matt what are your
initial thoughts because I think this is
very surprising to many fans on both
sides here surprising we talked about
this a lot on the Monday afternoon
showed that Matt rule obviously had a
connection to the New York Giants and
Pete thamel did a great job breaking
this news and it's always fun to be the
guy that gets to come in like the news
comes out and then you start you know
who to talk to right and so talking to
people on Tuesday morning the one thing
that I heard was that this is classic
Giants because they've done this before
they let their plans leak and then they
get passed over this happened in a
couple NFL Draft the Chicago Bears
traded up to get Leonard Floyd
Jack Conklin was another player that
they had targeted and got passed over
for so there have been those situations
and another side of that one key that I
was told by someone very much in the
know was that the Panthers went to Waco
Texas to meet Matt rule he went to Cabo
after the the bowl game tried to get
away with his family he got back in Waco
and I think this is a little bit of
hyperbole but I was told the Panthers
were there before his bags were unpacked
talking to him trying to present this
David Tepper basically fell in love
owner of the Panthers and said what is
it gonna take to get this done we don't
want you to get on that plane to go to
to Manhattan to meet the Giants and so
the Giants being a little stubborn maybe
or a little old-school thinking that
Matt rule needed to come to them so that
he can meet the Mara and Tish family so
that he could meet Dave gentlemen and
Kevin Abrams and everything that goes
into this huge football operation that
the Giants low feet caused him to miss
out on a guy who was a coach there and
so I think right now around the NFL a
lot of people are laughing at the New
York Giants because they hesitated and
lost their guy and this is what we've
seen from them in the past where like an
Eli Manning pass they Telegraph their
move and somebody jumps in and
intercepts them in this case it's Matt
rule that got picked off from them I
mean this is gigantic number one for the
Carolina Panthers because this is a team
and I can't state this enough that this
job was a highly desirable one around
the NFL before all these interviews took
place a lot of people look at David
Tepper and they say listen this is a
smart guy a forward-thinking guy with a
lot of money that wants to hire football
people to come in and run this operation
the right way number two they are gonna
build a mega facility down there it's
supposed to be you know sports altering
altering the landscape of football what
this thing is going to look like that
has hiring power as well listen the New
York Giants we talk about it a lot they
are definitely a historic franchise this
feels like a time where they've been
lapped they finally or they just got
caught up too and passed and they didn't
realize it and listen it's great that
they're in the New York market but at
the end of the day you need to be more
progressive why
Dave gentlemen still with this football
team if your Matt rule sitting there
you're going wide to work with them a
couple years he's gonna have influence
over draft picks we might disagree he's
still the GM it's almost like a stain
that won't go away where you said it on
the Monday show Matt Carolina is a clean
slate it's a place to go where Matt rule
has personnel influence he's getting a
mega deal because the owner believes in
him enough where he who traveled to him
and said I'm getting this done you're
not going up to East Rutherford and
meeting with anyone from the Giants I'm
not letting you go there and at the end
of the day rule can build this the way
he wants we talked about how her knee
it's probably a couple more years left
as GM there's gonna be a GM in the
waiting and rule is gonna have influence
over all of these football aspects of
the Panthers organization yeah exactly
and I think with this if your Matt rule
you grew up on Roosevelt Island which
you and I know that is that's pretty
damn close to Manhattan you go ahead and
call it New York I mean there's a New
York guy I mean yeah you're in the East
River you're a New York guy you've
worked for this ownership group and you
don't even take a meeting with them I
think that does there's egg on the face
of the New York Giants this morning and
I'm not trying to pile on but when you
go from hey we think we're gonna get
Matt rule - now you're requesting to
interview Jason Garrett that's where
you're at as a franchisee and you know
what when they hired Pat Shermer guess
what I said on the same podcast that's
all that's it
you can only hire Pat Shermer so I think
the Giants need to you know self scout a
little bit right now and say why are we
getting passed over why does Josh
McDaniels not want to come here why does
you know Matt rule not want to come here
why can't we reel in the big fish
anymore and yeah I don't know if it's
Dave gentlemen I don't know if it's the
split ownership group but there's
something there that needs to get
figured out and I was already being
reported the Giants are requesting
permission to speak with Jason Garrett
he's under contract for another week
even though the Cowboys are moving on
they have a new head coach Jason Garrett
is under contract until January 14th so
the Giants do have to request permission
they're obviously going to get it but
Jason Garrett does not move the needle
for me and I think he could be good for
Daniel Jones but we just saw nine years
of what this guy can do with a good
roster and it ain't great I just don't
know how I'm supposed to
excited about that it's extremely
underwhelming it's I saw you tweet it
great guy not an exciting head coaching
option right now it's as simple as that
the Giants should strive for more that's
one thing I want to make clear on this
podcast because we've been harsh on them
we haven't been the biggest fans of
Davey Edelman this is not just pile on
the Giants this is the Giant should be
better than this at the state of New
York football right now between the Jets
and the Giants I mean when they played
each other this year it was like the
embarrassment Bowl and you're really you
just saw what the Jets did a failed
division rival head coach they hire him
it looks like a mess this year now
you're gonna your fear the Giants you're
looking at that model and saying hey
let's go get the failed division rival
head coach because it works out so well
time and time again I just think this is
absolutely ridiculous and it's
interesting it's really interesting when
you look at the Panthers and you look at
the Giants two totally different
histories but now two teams going in
totally different directions it just
goes to show as the league changes we
just had the hundredth year as we go to
the NFL 101 it's going to change because
this old-school mentality of an iron
fist general manager is not gonna fly
with young coaches anymore Matt rules 44
years old do you think he wants to go
somewhere be Dave gentleman's whipping
boy he doesn't or does he want to go
somewhere and be beholding to Dave
gentleman's draft history no thanks no
maybe he doesn't believe in investing
all your capital and defensive tackles
and wants someone who you know hey I
want a quarterback I want wide receivers
you know let's let's rush the
quarterback I think that I think Dave
gentlemen has a bigger deterrent for the
New York Giants than they realized
and time will tell who's right on this
the Giants are us but I'm getting the
feeling a lot of people don't want to
work with Dave gentlemen and I think you
can look at the last two coaching cycles
for the New York Giants and there's some
proof in that pudding all right let's
move on buddy Henry rugs piggybacked a
little bit poor guy to a declares and
the whole football world stops
Henry rugs who has a chance to break the
40-yard dash record to the NFL Scouting
Combine declares and everybody's like oh
rugs is in but on the other side for
Alabama we've talked about how good they
self Scout and self recruit DeVotchKa
Smith is going back so Alabama loses one
speedy receiver keeps
the other de Montes myth everybody
remembers obviously the five touchdown
game he had believed was against
Tennessee in the 2019 season but Henry
rug's Connor in the draft as we I think
we expected there been some waffling as
of late Henry rugs everyone I've talked
to said that this kid has legendary
speed he allegedly ran a four to five at
the Alabama junior pro day and did that
without any combine training which we
know is incredibly important because it
will shave time off your forty if you
take it seriously if you work on firing
out of the block slow if you work on
your breathing if you work out
everything that goes into being a
sprinter you can shave serious time off
your forty and I think Henry rugs is
gonna spend the next seven weeks only
worried about the forty I don't think he
has to worry if he runs a four to one
nobody's gonna really remember what he
did in the short shuttle or how many
bench reps he threw up so I'm Henry rugs
I'm meeting with every Olympic sprinter
I can to try to shave some time off my
40 yeah I think this is a guy that can
clearly be a four to forty kind of
player I think it's gonna be fun to
watch him I don't want to make something
clear as well for the kind of athlete
rugs is which he should be in that you
know that the top percentile of wide
receivers that's the kind of testing
numbers we're gonna get from him I think
he's done some really nice things as a
wide receiver this year he grew from a
player that was a sprinter and a jet
sweep and a screens kind of guy to you
know the just the routes look really
sharp his releases are really sharp I
think he catches the ball well I think
he's rounding out his game for a young
player where you look at him and go this
is a ceiling player that we like the
floor right now but if he can keep
developing on the trajectory he's on
he's going to be a extremely good player
at the next level and probably a top 15
pick we'll be doing our mock draft in
segments 2 & 3 you'll see where we have
Henry rugs but my comp for him has been
all season long
Tyreke Hill and I think you can look at
and I mean like Tyreke as a rookie not
where he is now where he's blossom into
this fantastic number one receiver who's
really good at contested catches and not
just the downfield threat but I want to
use rugs in much the same way where yes
he can stretch the field vertically
but he's also a thick-bodied player that
I believe can win underneath on slants
on crossing routes
he's someone who'd you just want to get
him the ball you know just find a way to
get this guy the ball because what he
can do in space is absolutely electric
he's not the route runner the Jerry Judy
is he doesn't have sticky hands like
Devon to Smith but he is a powerful
runner I mean when you when people see
this guy not on the football field not
padded up his thighs are enormous I mean
he's lower bodies built like a running
back so what he can do in space is
really really special and you're gonna
hear it when we do the mock draft
receivers are gonna fly off the board so
I've had people like is there any way he
could fall to the Packers could he fall
to the bills could he fall to the Chiefs
first I want to see that dude speed on
the Kansas City offense like if someone
runs that fast John Ross was a top-10
pick had nothing going for him but speed
accordingly 20 surgeries exactly Henry
rug's is going to be picked pretty early
now let's keep it at Alabama to a total
by llola on Monday morning announces his
intention to enter the NFL Draft we
talked about that a lot on the Monday
afternoon podcast so if you missed that
and want to hear it go back to Monday's
podcast and you can hear I spend like 20
minutes on to him after the fact like I
said with the mat rule thing news breaks
it schoolers press conference the fun
part for me in my job is that then I get
to go in over the top and talk to people
involved with the decision because
they're more than we're apt to talk
after the fact talking to people at
Alabama talking to a couple agents about
twoa and where they expect him to be and
I don't mention scouts there because
they have not had a chance to get their
hands on him so if you talk to an area
scout right now about tool you're
probably not getting a lot of
information so I went to the agents who
were recruiting him and are plugged into
Alabama and people at Alabama who've
been around to it for the last three
years one thing that I heard and this is
a direct quote was that the medicals
look strong and positive so they feel
very good about where he was at when
that doctor's visit happened last Friday
now to us edit himself a lot won't be
known and this is what we've been
telling you guys a lot won't be known
until around the combine and so that
timeline is very important for him and
then obviously the early April medical
rechecks that will happen back in
Indianapolis that's big as well but I
did get this predict
from one I didn't reach out to this guy
he reached out to me one executive and
the AFC told me to uh still give me a
top five pick that is his prediction as
of now I mean I'm not surprised at all
when you look at it number one this is a
player that had number one overall
player talent let's make that very clear
and if the health concerns drop because
of medical rechecks
the demand for a quarterback into the
top five is going to keep two of their
and I think you have to talk about the
Miami Dolphins potentially planning a
move up let's not forget they have two
second-round picks there Matt we saw the
Jets spend three second-round picks to
go from six to three the Dolphins to go
from five to three might have to spend
two second-round picks in this draft or
there'll be other teams in the running
so I think when you look at this
situation with two uh the demand is
gonna be there I think teams are gonna
fully commit to that he's gonna need
time to rehab they're gonna have to
build an offensive line around him as
you should for every young quarterback
but especially what a player coming out
of college with multiple injuries I just
think the talent at this premium of a
position the position that you need is
gonna create a lot of buzz around tua
and cements him back into that top five
yeah I was trying to watch more Jedrek
wills this morning Tuesday morning right
before we recorded and I kept getting
caught watching to it I was watching the
LSU game and I hate when that happens
cuz like I need to watch the right
tackle and then your eyes start drifted
to the quarterback it's like yeah he's
he's so special with his touch and what
he does you mentioned there's gonna be a
lot of buzz whether it's the a team like
the Miami Dolphins trying to trade up
the LA Chargers the Carolina Panthers
now and Matt rule there there's
definitely gonna be a lot of interest
you'll hear where we have him right
after this break the New York Giants
have a head coach it's not Matt rule cuz
you're in the first segment he's go to
Carolina Matt rules domino falls the
Giants move quickly Connor to hire Joe
judge the special teams and wide
receiver coach for the New England
Patriots and I will be completely honest
I thought he was gonna get the
Mississippi State coaching job so he
gets a head coaching job it's just the
New York Giants and not Mississippi
State when this news came down you and I
were on a break and I'm not I'm not like
a break up we were on a break
from the show and and I said what I was
shocked because it felt like they would
go all in on someone like Josh McDaniels
and they don't they go to Joe judge and
I'll let you go first and then I'll fill
you in on it because I've actually I've
been texting quite a few people
throughout the rest of the show and and
will let you know what I've heard back
well I think for me the biggest question
is because I'm not gonna sit here and
act like I'm a Joe judge expert alright
I don't know what is so you're good I
don't have ears in New England to know
his day-to-day responsibilities over the
last couple years I think he's only been
the wide receivers coach for about eight
to nine months right now so he's really
a special teams guy which is not an
insult there's a lot of great special
teams coaches around the NFL and
obviously John Harbaugh comes to mind
but also Matt this goes back to when we
evaluate quarterbacks every year not
every day three quarterback is Tom Brady
so will Joe judge be an outlier that
he's great at this I don't know my
question for me
the foreveryone is who is his offensive
coordinator for Daniel Jones because
he's not running the offense with Daniel
Jones who's gonna be his defensive
coordinator you know what is what does a
Joe judge team coach team look like and
this is such a 50/50 hire because there
are so many variables in so many
question marks that we can't answer
right now I do think it's ridiculous to
see the spin going on that you know the
Matt rule wasn't it wasn't their top
clear-cut guy Matt rule was the Giants
clear-cut guy the Giants are stunned
that Matt rule went to Carolina he got a
60 million dollar deal that can be worth
up to 70 million dollars incentives
I believe Ian Rapoport said that Matt
rule or his party did call the Giants
and say hey you know you can match this
deal if you want they declined not to I
just want to make it clear here
the Giants missed on Matt rule and
pivoting to Joe judge I'm not saying
it's a bad move I'm curious to see how
it plays out but I'll say this it is a
gigantic risk and I think it's going to
be a very interesting sell to the New
York Giants fans and it also makes me
wonder how in control is Dave Gettleman
still of this franchise because who made
this higher is my biggest question you
I'll fill in some of the gaps for you
that judge based on what I've heard so
one thing that I I'm trying to like read
all my text and talk at the same time I
apologize
one thing I've heard is that Jason
Garrett is his pick to be offensive
coordinator now we are recording this at
about 10:30 Central Time on Tuesday
morning so by the time you hear this
Wednesday that information might change
but what I'm reading right now turns the
text is that Jason Garrett would be his
guy I'm talking to a player who was
under Joe judge previously and here's
what he told me this is the guy when
Bill Belichick couldn't be there he ran
the room he's incredibly intelligent he
won two titles at Bama and then went to
New England he's been there since 2012
so this player that I'm talking to and
hopefully we can get him to come on the
podcast maybe next week
he feels like Joe judge was going to be
a head coach it was just a matter of
time so like we've said before maybe
it's better to be a year early than a
year late he's only 38 years old he just
turned 38 years old and again this is a
guy that has won five championships in
the last little bit of time with Bama
and with New England so the player I'm
talking to is very very excited about
this feels like Joe judge is the right
hire for the Giants Connor but of course
there's a little bit of a bias there
because you this this guy played for
Judge so I think it's it's fascinating
that they went to they went away from
the good ol boys club which is not what
we expected with Dave gentlemen because
it feels like at times he is the anchor
chair of the good ol boys club so to
step away from here and say you know we
want to go with the 38 year old guy we
want to tap into that Belichick Nick
Saban coaching tree and shake things up
a little bit I think of your Giants fan
you gotta feel pretty damn good about
that that it's not oh my god we're
hiring Jason Garrett as head coach or we
hired Mike McCarthy I don't know if this
will work because frankly there's not
enough sample size about Joe judge to
make an informed opinion but I know a
lot of people around the NFL that I
trust are really excited for the Giants
because that they are getting an
infusion of youth and in a very very
smart coach here yeah I think that
should that is something to be excited
about it would have been very
disappointing if the Giants hired you
know Jason Garrett as the I wouldn't
even want Josh McDaniels that much to be
honest with you I was very underwhelmed
as first go-around
a head coach I think he might be one of
those guys that might always be a good
coordinator but once again there are
just so many variables with Joe judge
right now that it's hard I want to see
his staff number one and then I want to
see the direction this team takes in the
NFL Draft especially if they can
potentially move out of that number four
pick or how are they gonna approach the
draft let's be real Matt they sell a lot
of rebuilding left to do on this roster
so this is the ultimate wildcard of the
offseason this is one of the bigger
wildcard hires we've seen in a very long
time and there's plenty of optimism to
be had about this hire and there's
plenty of questions to be raised about
this hire I will say this my button on
the whole topic is if Bill Belichick
trusts you to be a special teams and
receivers coach you gotta be pretty damn
good and so and I know we haven't seen a
lot of Belichick guys have success away
from the nest maybe maybe this is the
one and I think the Giants getting a 38
year old head coach and it's you can
understand they want to build Bill
Belichick was kind of always the one
that got away as an assistant they tap
back into that coaching tree a little
bit so we'll see Tom will tell and maybe
by Wednesday we'll know who the
offensive coordinator is but definitely
a mix-up here you know we thought that
we would see them go Jason Garrett Josh
McDaniels the Giants shake things up so
segment one is a little bit outdated now
but that's okay that's what happens in
the NFL news breaks and we jump back in
to cover it so let's take a break we
come back mock draft Wednesday the draft
order is now set for 24 teams we know
one through 24 who it's gonna be the
Cincinnati Bengals are on the clock
first and if this is your first time
listening to stick to football welcome
you're gonna have fun but what do we
tell you every week is Joe burrow is
gonna be the number one pick so I'm not
gonna change that now Joe burrow number
one Cincinnati Bengals my analysis
you got to draft the best quarterback in
college football you got to draft the
best quarterback in this draft class
Joey borrow fifty five touchdowns 75%
completion percentage he's from Ohio
the Bengals need a restart under Zach
Taylor I would be excited about this as
a Bengals fan you got Tyler boy
Joe Mixon Jonah Williams gonna be
healthy next year and now you add in the
Heisman Trophy winner Joe borough I
think it's a really good fit exact
Ahlers offense and this is a similar
argument for me here at number two with
the Washington Redskins you take chase
young I know there's gonna be a lot of
questions do they try to auction this
pick do they you know convince somebody
to move up for tua and get more draft
selections let's not forget they don't
have a number two I believe because of
the montz has sweat trade up from last
year so this is a team that could use
more draft capital but chase young is
too good of a player you get a premier
piece for your front 7 I think Ron
Rivera it would be really excited about
getting this guy in it with the Redskins
and I think this is just a simple one I
don't think there'll be a trade package
good enough to entice them to move off
of taking chase young it counter to your
point I get asked a lot and I think some
people are just Lions fans and want
chase young to fall but they're always
like of course wouldn't you at least
take the call and I'm reminded I know we
just kind of made fun of Dave gentlemen
I'm reminded of Dave gentlemen refusing
to pick up the phone to talk about
trades because he wanted to say call
Barkley so bad chase Young is that level
of prospect but in a more important
position so if I'm Ron Rivera and
somebody calls and says hey we want to
come up and get chase young unless man
there's no way there's absolutely no way
that I would take the unless it's like
here's four first-round picks like I'm
going to need so much in order to trade
out of a player who has everything you
want at arguably the second-most
position in football so for everyone who
asked all the time like wouldn't you
even consider it the only way I'm
considering it is a completely
unrealistic trade package from a team
that I feel really good is gonna be
terrible for the next couple years so
when I look at it nuts
chase young not to go out draft day on
y'all but it's chase young no matter
what at 3:00 the Detroit Lions we've
said it for a while now this is where
the draft starts and I do feel like the
Lions have options I'm gonna give them
Derek Brown defensive tackle from Auburn
I just feel like he's a really really
special player you know Melo and I have
had a lot of scouting conversations
about him whether it's does he remind
you of Adamic ensued as you remind you
of Chris Jones is it you know a little
DeForest Buckner to his game he is
incredibly impactful and I feel like in
a
in a class without chase young he would
be the number one defender in it he is
everything you want from a defensive
tackle and I know that we've been burned
a little bit by defensive tackles the
last couple trashy like Quintin Williams
who's incredibly young didn't make a big
splash as a rookie but this is about a
five-year plan not a one-year plan I
would be tempted by Jeff Okuda Here I am
not tempted by to it at this spot I am
may be one of the few Matt Stafford
believers out there but I still Malia
Stafford is good enough if he actually
had more than one receiver at a time
that was good at football and had a
better supporting staff that Stafford
could be good enough to win you an NFC
North so I'm gonna take Derek Brown here
yeah I think Stafford is far from being
the problem in Detroit so I like the pic
Derek Browns a great player and that
means that number four the New York
Giants it's not all bad for your New
York Giants fan so you get a great
player in Jeff Okuda they need a corner
they obviously moved on from juniors
Jenkins
you know the Eli Apple pick from a
couple years ago didn't work out this is
a team that's gonna need some help in
the secondary and Jeff Okuda is a
premier corner you can build around in
your secondary he is a number one shut
down man-to-man corner so this is a
no-brainer for the New York Giants at
number four yeah it really is and last
year they drafted DeAndre Baker would
pick 32 overall I think it was and so
now you have a young nucleus corner to
really go with to really build around I
love Jeff Okuda like I said I considered
him at 3 number 5 this is where our guy
- it does come off the board the Miami
Dolphins a team that we talked about it
in August we thought they were tanking
for - a well they didn't take
they beat the last two Super Bowl
winners got the number five pick they
still get their guy this obviously
deserves the world's biggest asteroid
because if two is not healthy you got to
go a different direction here and that
might be Justin Herbert it might be a
free agent but I think - it in this spot
it's a good one for him Fitzpatrick
complain until - is ready and then you
unleash to it and your other two
first-round picks on the NFL next year
yeah listen number five they can't pass
up taking - I think they're gonna have
to plan some options to make sure they
go up and get him to secure that
franchise quarterback for them but I
like to fit for them you know listen
Ryan Fitzpatrick you're gonna play
probably one more year there that's okay
- who's got to get healthy so that's a
good land
spot number six the Los Angeles chargers
listen I don't know what's gonna happen
with Phillip Rivers but I do know this
is a team that needs to prioritize the
offensive line here
I like Jedrek wills in this spot you can
go get yourself a franchise tackle I
think you can play on the left side
we've seen them play on the right side
it can even play guard if you need but
this guy's gonna be a tackle here so for
the Chargers I know they've you know
invested a lot of resources to make this
unit better they've had some bad injury
luck at times it happens to the Chargers
year after year hopefully that doesn't
happen with whoever they take in this
spot will should be the guy I love this
pick and as you know the last couple
weeks I've been doing a lot of tape
study on guys when they declare Jedrek
wills is my number one offensive tackle
in this class we love him for Carolina
Derek series for Los Angeles goodness
number seven is Carolina I'm on the
clock and I originally had Andrew Thomas
in the spot and I said you know what no
you got a new owner you got a new head
coach you need a new quarterback I know
I bang the drum for it why don't you
keep Kyle Allen
but that was about salary it was about
building on a cheap contract not on the
idea that Kyle Allen was some great
quarterback that you could win Super
Bowls with will Grier I didn't really
look great either I think it's time to
just go and hit that reset button with
Matt rule coming in now I'm not the
biggest Justin Herbert guy but he does
have some undeniable traits and we've
seen a couple guys where if you get in
the right situation and you can turn
those traits into you know positive
habits as quarterbacks to be pretty
successful now - the fourth-quarter
meltdown Josh Allen is one of those guys
I don't think he and Justin Herbert are
all that dissimilar so Justin Herbert is
seven I know it's not the most exciting
pick but you got a guy at six foot six
240 pounds did not turn the ball over in
college has a very strong right arm and
I think in his senior year showed a lot
more toughness than we had given him
credit for previously so there are
things to like about Herbert and if rule
can put in a system that will take
advantage of his strengths his mobility
I think they might be able to have
something here with what they have and
DJ more Christian McCaffrey his targets
for him I was gonna say we know Herbert
could throw the ball down the field you
have DJ Moore coming off a year with 87
catches and almost 1200 receiving yards
we know a Christian McCaffrey could do
he's the best running back in football
maybe Robbie Anderson as we sit on
Monday follows rule to Carolina you got
a vertical big play offense there
and that would be a lot of fun to watch
number nine Jacksonville the
Jacksonville Jaguars here another team
listen
out number eight Cardinals getting ahead
of myself there Matt I don't want to
take your pig for the Cardinals here we
talk about this every single time we do
a mock draft we don't know how much
they're gonna truly invest in the
offensive line under Kliff Kingsbury
that remains to be seen but we know they
want this to be a big play explosive
offense with Kyler Murray and that's why
I don't think Jerry Judi gets by this
spot and there's no luck that Judi goes
in the top ten picks for as good as he
is
I think the wide receiver class as being
as deep it as it as it is is gonna push
some guys down the board I think Judy's
too talented to get out of this spot I
think he would be such a slam-dunk in
that offense that this almost becomes a
no-brainer as much as they have needs
other spots wide receiver is still big
one in Arizona and I think to your point
Connor we all love Jared Judy I think
he's inside the top five players for all
of us
I really enjoy him but I think this year
is unique in that give me a couple
quarterbacks go early and then we
actually have some competent offensive
tackles there's chase youngins Derrick
brown is Jeff Okuda so you're getting
players at positions that are more of a
premium so they're most likely going to
go ahead at Jerry Judy now the Lions of
Giants could fall in love with Judy and
he could go there obviously but I think
we're seeing a possibility that the
receivers Judy lamb all of them slip a
little bit from where they're actually
ranked number nine excuse me number nine
the Jacksonville Jaguars I'm going to
Andrew Thomas here cam Robinson God love
him is just not good and so you got to
get better at left tackle I still have a
little bit of questions about Andrew
Thomas I feel like he misses way too
often with his hands I just want to see
him be a little bit more accurate but he
does have the power when he misses to
usually reset and recover it has very
very good strength he's smart he's
poised I think Andrew Thomas could be an
answer at left tackle and if he's not I
think he could be an all-pro guard so is
one of those spots were okay
Dennis Daly and cam Robinson and the
crew that's not getting it done
let's bring in this guy but worst case
scenario he's going to be a starter for
you for a long time I'm with you there I
still really like Andrew Thomas and do
you think the flu
or for him is a very very talented guard
it's like almost a more premium version
of what Cody Ford was last year
that's how Andrew Thomas is where you're
like I know he could be a you know kind
of a mauler at guard but he's probably
gonna start out at tackle and I think
Ford had his fair share of highs and
lows this year but a lot of bright spots
as well number 10 the Cleveland Browns
they get the last one on this run of
offensive linemen if Tristan wharfs
declares that's the big question right
now but with this pick it's got to be
Tristan Dwarfs the Browns need to
protect Baker Mayfield we saw him
leaving clean pockets at times this year
as well so he's just a little shook
right now is what it is they need to
build that wall around him they need to
you know prioritize the trenches again
we know they have a lot of skill talent
and they think they found their guy at
quarterback but once again they need to
boost up this offensive line wharfs
plays right tackle this year he can play
guard once again he has more of the
build of a guard I'm actually very
curious to see his overall measurements
but the way he flows seamlessly to the
second level of the field and sets up
long run plays is really really
impressive and I think for Nick Chubb
for Baker Mayfield this would be a great
ad yeah I like that as well you got it
you got to protect those guys number 11
the New York Jets and I apologize to
resident New York Jets fan Connor
Rodgers all the tackles are gone and I'm
doing as well what happens here is you
end up in a situation and I think it's
important to run through these scenarios
because Joe Douglas as general manager
is very unlikely to draft an on premium
position and that by that I would add a
wide receiver in that group out you know
they're not have drive to safety
obviously they're not your draft a
linebacker most likely but there are
none of those positions available here
there's not an edge rusher that I value
at 11 and I don't include a japanesse in
that group because of the defense that
the Jets run under Gregg Williams epinet
is just not a very good fit and so I
think you look at the board and say what
do we do here and I'm going to give the
Jets Edie lamb I love the way he plays
yes I have questions about his speed and
if he'll be able to separate against NFL
coverage but you cannot dispute how
tough and physical he is his catch
radius is enormous for his listed size
of
six foot 390 pounds CD you can have
concerns about the scheme ease coming
out of and how quickly he'll acclimate
while also loving his game and that's
why I'm at so if you can't protect Sam
Donald and number 11 overall better give
him someone he can throw the ball to
because I think Robbie Anderson is about
to be a Carolina Panther listen here's
another point that we've run this
simulation almost every week for weeks
now and this happens a lot if you're the
Jets and trust me teams do this teams do
mock draft simulators with way smarter
systems than anything that exists on
podcasts on the internet anything like
that they have their own systems the
Jets have to be sitting there and saying
listen there's a good chance one of the
top tackles is not available to us and
that kind of changes your free agency
and trades plan doesn't it Matt you
might have to be a little more
aggressive on that front knowing at 11
we know Joe Douglas would love to take
an offensive lineman it just might not
be available in that spot 12 the Las
Vegas Raiders that's right we're moving
on we call them the Vegas Raiders this
is no brainer we do it every week they
get Isaiah Simmons this is a seamless
fit this guy could play inside
linebacker outside linebacker he could
rush the passer
he could play safety he can cover in the
slot he's basically a superhero a
transformer on defense that's what he's
like he just molds into whatever
position you need him to go into and for
the Vegas Raiders this is once again
just a grand slam of a pic they have two
first-round picks in this draft and I
love the spot they're into 12
if Isaiah Simmons went fourth or third I
wouldn't be surprised
neither would I here at 12 is like how
do you get that lucky number 13 the
Indianapolis Colts we've had a lot of
conversations about a receiver maybe
help at corner where do they go if
Anthony Costanza retires there no
tackles worth drafting here it's a three
tackle draft the way I see it right now
I think the Colts and Chris Ballard
would take one look at a japanesse ax
and realized that Justin Houston in
jabal sheared our older guys and to
Ballard's what credit we've given him as
a scout as an evaluator as GM has not
been able to find pass rushers bin bono
gu looks like a situational guy Taekwon
lewis has been bumped inside more to a
tackle roll they need a pass rusher
those guys always her exactly they might
be different
they are here so I think you look at the
coal say can we get a difference-maker a
JEP Anessa was the difference maker for
I was the last two years he could play
for three defensive and he can bump in
to play tackle when needed he can be
special thing the only reason he falls
to 13 is he's a little bit what we used
to call a tweener a little bit of a
tackle it's a little bit of an end and I
think that might make him more of a 4:3
fit for teams yeah I think so too and I
like that landing spot a lot listen the
coats have it taking swings on mid round
pass rushers and we know the fail rate
on those guys is it's through the roof
let's be real if you don't take a guy on
round one the chance of hitting on a
pass rusher outside of those picks is
from as drastically low so this is
probably a year they prioritize that
spot 14 the Buccaneers still got Todd
Bowles there and you still need more
help in the secondary grant Delta is the
pick now you know me and Matt were kind
of chopping it up before the show we're
very curious to see what happens with
Delta does he own this process does he
speak to why the film his final year at
LSU was not as promising as the first
two years where he looks like a
superstar at safety does he test very
well Delpit is one of the more volatile
players in this draft start of the year
as a top-five guy now he's sitting in
that top 15 range does he fall all the
way back to the end of round one but
once again I think this is a really
really good scheme fit and I still
believe in Delp it's talent yeah I do
too i he's one of those guys I was
actually talking to an NFL safety about
Grant dumped it on Sunday and it was
like I feel like he's gonna turn it back
on and everybody's gonna look stupid who
dropped him down but I've seen it before
yep Durban James it's a little bit of a
risk for sure 15 the Denver Broncos I
like what they have here drew Loch
Courtland Sutton two really good players
they got something adult and Ryanair I'm
excited to see the development of Noah
fan so you look at this roster it's like
okay where do we go I think it's a
little bit early for corner here even
though we're about to see a run on it I
want to go defensive line because this
is by far the best value and I do think
it's a need so I'm gonna give them Javon
Kinlaw I've compared him to Ark Armstead
in terms of a guy that big six foot six
310 pounds he could play he's athletic
enough to play defensive end in a
three-four he could play defensive
tackle he's going to be able to get
after the quarterback he can stop the
run
when they get drafted Raymont Jones last
year I think if you put Javon kianlawl
jeremiah jones as your bookends you're
in a pretty damn good spot on defense
for that three-four scheme
obviously you got von miller Bradley
Chubb coming back from injury so you're
in a good spot yeah I considered strong
safety and corner here but Kendall is
just too good to pass up at this spot
yeah he's one of those players that you
know kind of like Christian Wilkins last
year he's just you know flying under the
radar played really really well this
year I think I'll have a really good
senior bowl and he'll just be a top 20
pick that doesn't get this overwhelming
amount of hype number 13 overall player
yeah and how often do we I mean we got
to speak to him we loved the guy but how
often do we talk about him so it's it's
really you know I'm glad he's gonna be
at the Senior Bowl because I think
that'll start the hype train back up a
little bit
16 the Atlanta Falcons this semi is just
one of the easiest picks in the mock
draft they need a corner Christian
Fulton's on the board i like christian
fulton a lot he's a top 20 player at a
premium position Atlanta needs to get
better in this area they just couldn't
play past defense this year and I think
they had a awful starts of the year but
I think this could be a bounce-back team
in 2020 and I think Fulton is a day one
starter yeah I think so as well
let's take a break we come back pick 17
to 32 last segment of the day number 17
the Dallas Cowboys and Mike McCarthy
that's can take some getting used to we
talked about it on the Monday show this
is a team has 26 free agents a lot of
holes to fill one of those most likely
being Byron Jones who was gone as a free
agent I'm gonna give them CJ Henderson a
player that I've compared in terms of
technique to today vyas white I don't
know if he's gonna get into a scheme
that allows him to flourish like tre has
in Buffalo but I see a lot of
similarities between these two players
yeah listen I'm with you all the way
there the Cowboys need a corner we did
the fixing the Cowboys segment on Monday
and I know that you know you had grants
out but going to them I'd call commit
heard back from a lot of Cowboys fans
and I agree that you know there's a lot
on the table for them whether it's
safety whether it's tight end whether
it's corner and I think as you see a run
here as grants help it's gone Christian
Fulton's gone they jump on a corner
they're in Henderson 18 the Miami
Dolphins this selection is from the
Pittsburgh Steelers in the
Fitzpatrick trade Henri rugs come on
down this is a slam-dunk right here I
think rugs is a top-15 kind of player
that you fall 2:18 the Dolphins need
offense yet they got to earlier in this
trap - of throwing - Henry rugs we've
seen how that works out before his speed
his athleticism like I said him in
Devante Parker talked about skill talent
for your young quarterback coming in
they're talking about skilled talent for
Ryan Fitzpatrick and camp and to open up
the season next year
I just think rogue should not fall any
further than this yeah we talked about
this dude a lot he can absolutely fly
and it's gonna open up that offense and
gets back with a guy who's pretty gonna
throw in him the football number 19 the
Las Vegas Raiders from the Chicago Bears
we had them somehow getting Isaiah
Simmons at 12 well another player falls
right into their lap t Higgins from
Clemson this dude will Moss you in the
red zone he is so good
attacking the football six-foot for 215
pounds I've compared him to AJ Green I
don't know who's gonna be throwing him
the football in 2020
it's Derek Carr he Chambre very very
happy it might be Tommy we'll see the T
Higgins is a great value here and is a
huge need for the Raiders 20
Jacksonville is back up again thanks to
the Jalen Ramsey trade here and listen
they had to get a corner now because
they lost one in Jalen Ramsey Paulson a
Depot we're gonna see this run on
corners we saw it you know Cudas gonna
go in the top five we think top seven
Fulton goes here to 16 and then you have
CJ Henderson so the corner starts to
come off the board
Jacksonville can't miss that run a Depot
went healthy this year and last year was
a very very talented player and I think
for Jacksonville this is the beginning
to you know getting back on track of
what your roots are this is a defensive
team and we know a Deebo is a very very
talented high IQ athletic kind of
cornerback yeah I am a big fan of him I
just want to see how he runs because
that's the only question number 21 the
Philadelphia Eagles you saw in the
playoff games man and it's so
heartbreaking to see Carson Wentz not be
able to be out on the field for that one
but they need wide receivers no
disrespect a great word jr. it's a great
story they need receivers they need
playmakers ylvis' cachet Nault he's a
playmaker the dude it has speed for days
a great playmaker in the open field we
talked about Henry rugs Shane Hall it
could be like Henry rugs little brother
it very similar type players just find a
way
get him the football whether it's jet
sweeps pop passes screen game middle the
field he can stretch the field I think
Shane oh it could just be a little bit
of a utility knife offensively for the
Philadelphia Eagles all right keeping it
going with wide receivers here the bills
we know they need one and they need a
bigger guy they have John Brown there
they have Cole Beasley
so it's 22 here go with Justin Jefferson
now he's he's a skinnier wide receiver
but he's got good length he's tall and I
think he plays very very tough I think
he's maybe one of the most underrated
football players in this draft class
right now and for the bills listen you
just need to build around Josh Allen I
know there's been a lot of highs and
lows with him I don't know if I'm even
fully sold that he's the guy but they
have a great defense they're well
coached team they hit on a lot of picks
last year whether it was Devon's motor
Singletary whether it was Dawson Knox so
there was Cody Ford they've done a lot
of Ede Oliver they've done a lot of
really good things there they need to
stick to their board continue drafting
and this also fills a need Jefferson is
a great player well and like what we
heard from the bills from Brandon being
the GM after the playoff loss was we
need to score more points
justin jefferson helps you score a lot
more points number 23 the New England
Patriots I've said it before I can't
ever remember the Patriots original pick
being this low it's shocking and I think
the rebuild is going to start whether
Tom Brady is back next year or not they
have to address the tight end position
we know how important that is to them is
such a safety valve in Josh McDaniels
offense Cole commit we thought he was
going back to Notre Dame to be a closer
on the baseball team he decided the end
of the draft I believe he's a
first-round player he's a little bit of
a throwback this dude can block he's
gonna be excellent tracking the ball in
the middle of the field from a body comp
standpoint he reminds me a little bit of
Kyle Rudolph a little bit of Travis
Kelce I mean he is a grown-ass man and
65 260 pounds so this isn't some little
Flex tight end running out routes trying
to make people miss he will run over you
you don't want to compare anyone to Rob
Gronkowski but I think their usage could
be very very similar here yeah usage
definitely you know they're big bodied
pass catchers they can work the seam I
think commit was pretty reliable as a
run blocker nobody will be like Gronk
was but at the end of the day this is a
really really good offensive fit and
speaking of that at 24 for the same
they need a wide receiver across her
Michael Thomas KJ Hamlet has the speed
to be that guy he's always open he's got
tremendous speed he's great with the
ball in his hands after the catch and I
think in this offense we're gonna find
out is Drew Brees gonna stick around is
this gonna be Teddy's offense is this to
taste some he'll show for good not just
spurts of it Hamlet is a guy that he's
gonna light up the track size is gonna
concern some teams I don't think the
Saints will have those concerns though
and we saw what they did with Brandon
cooks I know they moved on from him
quick but Hamlet is kind of a similar
player maybe with even more speed yeah
and I saw I guess you don't believe that
Antonio Brown will be there next year
he's gonna be boxing Logan Paul was the
latest news number 25 the Tennessee
Titans when Connor and I before we were
recorded we were talking about this
Pickens like where do you go with
Tennessee they I think they need another
edge rusher but not a small guy like a
grouse meadows
it's Ray Lewis maybe from Alabama would
be a fit here but everything I've heard
they have not worked on a long-term deal
with Derrick Henry who is their offense
and if you lose Derrick Henry you can't
just turn to Dion Lewis guys you're
gonna have to replace them it is a deep
running back class so maybe they feel
comfortable waiting but as of today
subject to change I'm giving them JK
Dobbins running back from Ohio State
I've been so impressed by his vision his
burst his power between the tackles you
know you could talk about DeAndre Swift
or Travis etn in this spot I don't think
they're a good fit for that offensive
scheme I think Dobbins is which is why I
have him coming off the board as the
first running back here oh man he would
be a home run in Tennessee I'm talking
like maybe top 5 pick in fantasy kind of
home run that's how good that scheme fit
is there and I want to make this a
conversation then Matt what does Derrick
Henry's value it's interesting right it
is it's interesting I mean I think first
it's like you have to is there a market
you know because we saw that with levy
on bail okay what is your market you
know because what he wanted and what the
NFL felt like he was worth Derrick Henry
just turned 26 years old last week but
he's had 800 carries already in the NFL
so I think that is it's a legitimate
question of what type of contract do you
give a guy who has been so much better
than I expect
by the way the last year-and-a-half been
great unbelievable
but how what's have a contract you give
a guy who is a big back that takes a lot
of hits and is you know 26 years old and
we've seen you know it used to be 30
starting to feel like it's like 28 when
running backs fall off so I think if
you're the Titans you have to think with
your head and not your heart and say
what have good running backs done on
second contracts they're not living up
to it Todd Gurley fell off a cliff I
mean it just it's it's sad to see but so
I think with Henry maybe he's back with
the Titans but I don't think it's on
some you know record-breaking lucrative
deal like a lot of people might expect
yeah maybe they just slapped a franchise
tag on him and hope he shows up that's
really the best bet for them 26 the
Minnesota Vikings this might be viewed
as a reach on corner but I think Gladney
is a top of second round player that for
being a cornerback will go at the end of
the first depending what he does in
mobile depending how he runs I loved the
film though Xavier Rhodes cannot run
anymore and that me usually means that
cornerback in the NFL you can't play
anymore at least you can't start anymore
so Jeff Gladney the fit to Minnesota is
just what they need yeah it really isn't
like I told you I have him at 35 I don't
feel like this is that much of a reach
because of that run that we saw on the
corner position number 27 the Miami
Dolphins we've given them to us we've
given them Henry rugs as I've said
before you can't go into 2020 with Ryan
Fitzpatrick as your leading rusher he
was this past year you gotta fix that
and I know this is not the pick Dolphins
fans what there's not a left tackle
worth drafting here so I'm going to take
DeAndre Swift you cannot and you can't
reach it the offensive tackle position I
think that's one thing we've learned
instead of going that route I'm gonna
take Jay Andre Swift here look to baby
try to get a Trent Williams try to
address that left tackle spot a little
bit later in the draft where you're not
so heavy on the capital side of things
but G Andre Swift I've compared him to
Alvin Kamara in terms of type of back to
he is catch out of the backfield
he has very very good speed great
agility good vision I think people are
jaded because he was hurt at the end of
the year with that shoulder injury but
JA dry swift for the entire college
football season we were talking about is
the number one running back in this
class this is a very good value for the
Dolphins yeah I still think he's the
best
back in a very very good group with
Dobyns JT I mean the list really goes on
and on 28 the Seattle Seahawks this a
little bit of a fall for him but I love
the landing spot eat or gross may doze
from Penn State we know what they can do
with athletic pass rushers it's gonna be
interesting to see you know what happens
would you Davey on clowny going forward
and if we've learned anything about the
Seahawks Matt they just keep stacking
the deck with front seven guys year
after year they will keep swinging they
will just stick hit after hit in the
draft and I think for gross may dos this
is the place where he can go become that
double-digit sack kind of player yeah
especially if Jadeveon Clowney is not
back that is a huge need for them number
29 the Green Bay Packers it feels like
we've given everyone in the world a
receiver right now which affects the
depth even guys like Justin Jefferson
who you know we've kind of thought oh
he'll be like it you know 29 to 32 pick
is off the board but the Packers need a
receiver and I am willing to take a
chance on potential here with Gabe Davis
from Central Florida game is 6-3 to 15
you can watch him body people with quick
slants he's very physical my only
question is speed he might be a 4 6 guy
and if that's the case he'll probably
fall down and not be a second-round pick
but I think opposite Davante Adams his
physicality what he can do on breaking
ground should be very very nice in this
Green Bay offense yeah they need a
receiver they really really do and we've
said it over and over again I know you
know they were kind of hoping around the
trade deadline Packers fans that they
would do something but you know they
standard they stead Pat and I think this
is a good spot of the draft where you'll
get someone that could step on the field
right away whether it's Davis whether
it's Donovan peoples Jones there will be
a lot of talent on the board available
for them 30 Kansas City Chiefs one of
the easiest picks I've had to make in
this mock draft Kenneth Murray is still
on the board I know some Chiefs fans mad
are gonna look at running back here you
know they're gonna say hey we'd love to
see Jonathan Taylor Nachi Harris sorry
guys I don't see the GM doing that and
guess what Kenneth Murray is a great
player would be a great linebacker for
them and they got to build this defense
through the draft or continue to build
this defense through the draft on some
cheap contracts
I know Chiefs fans I get asked about
running back a receiver all the time
I really feel like they need a three
down middle linebacker and a smart one
they need a smart linebacker they'll
have to
corners under contract next year to
various Ward and Rashad fittin there's
no corner worth drafting here or like
Sammy Watkins could be gone I don't know
if Michaels ready to elevate to a wide
receiver to spot so receiver could be a
need the Chiefs have plenty of needs
interior offensive line
I don't think Brett Veatch is the type
of guy that would draft a running back
this early and I truly don't believe
he's the type of guy that would draft a
receiver this year
Mikko last year was more thing a
response to what was happening with the
Tyreke Hill allegations and where they
were at in terms of you know hey we were
trying to my Super Bowl we got to plug
that hole so I think with the Chiefs it
should be a defense heavy draft this
year number 31 the San Francisco 49ers
they have to trade out of this pick but
we know do trades in our mock drafts
they don't have a pick and Rams 2 3 4 or
5 they have to trade out of this spot
here though I'm gonna give them Xavier
McKinney everyone knows one of my
favorite players for them he has played
free and strong safety which i think is
great for this defense he could do it
all he has range over the top I've seen
him rush the quarterback I think he has
very very good run defense
I like McKinney I don't think the gap
between he and grant dealt but it's
really that great so the 49er somehow
keep this pick McKinney would be the guy
that I would want here yeah if you were
purely grading on film from 2019
McKinney would be rated higher than Zell
Pitt right now I think that's pretty
fair to say 32 the Baltimore Ravens
Mathieu Don is probably gonna get paid a
lot of money in free agency ain't great
for him the Ravens will have to replace
another front 7 players so I go with
Curtis Weaver here and Curtis Weaver
highly productive player I want to you
know kind of drop the nugget here the
big question for him is how is he gonna
test you know is he going to be an
athletic kind of guy I think it's gonna
be really interesting for him because
the film is great but once again is he
athletic enough to be that premier kind
of pass rusher at the next level that's
gonna be the difference between him
being a day to pick end of end of day
one pick yeah you know I'll be
transparent I have Curtis Weaver I was
just trying to find him and then phone
is blowing up like crazy
I have Curtis Weaver 77 overall my board
his adduction was amazing there were
times I watched him plane it was like I
his conditioning just looks bad and so
we've seen this in the past I mean think
of Jake I polite you know is another
guys like your film looks first-round
but then you get into the testing
process and it's like can't do it
because you just you're not athletic
enough but I think Curtis Weaver fits
that mold 6-3 to 55 I've actually heard
he's probably like closer to 270 but he
has some speed rush skill that makes you
sit up in your chair when you're
watching him he's athletic I just don't
know how explosive he is so I'm excited
to see he's one of those guys
underclassmen we'll see him at the
combine I think that's gonna be huge for
him all right that is our show I know we
promised you guys draft on draft and
then the NFL went crazy Joe judge gets
hired Maddie rule gets hired we had to
give you a mock draft so that is our
show Friday is gonna be a fun one I
don't want to give them anything away
Friday is gonna be a fun show make sure
you're ready for Friday morning when you
wake up we are going to have a good one
for Conor I'll talk to you all real soon